Who has words to capture that night's disaster? Tell that slaughter. What tears could match our torments now? An ancient city is falling, a power that ruled for ages, now in ruins. Everywhere lie the motionless bodies of the dead, strewn in her streets, her homes and the gods shrines. All over now.
谁有言语能捕捉那晚的灾难？诉说那场屠杀。如今又有何种泪水能与我们的苦难相称？一座古老的城市正在陷落，一个统治了数个世纪的强权，如今已成废墟。到处都是死者僵硬的尸体，散落在她的街道、家园和神殿中。一切都结束了。
Devouring fire, whipped by the winds, goes churning into the rooftops, flames searching over them, scorching blasts raging up the sky. Treasure hauled from burning temples, the sacramental tables, bowls of solid gold, and the holy robes seized from every quarter, the enemy piling high the plunder. Children and trembling mothers rounded up in a long, endless line. So that was the greatest of all Roman poets Virgil, and he was writing almost two centuries after Hannibal's Great War Against the Romans, the subject of this epic series,
狂风卷起的吞噬之火，翻滚着冲向屋顶，火焰在上方搜寻，灼热的气浪在天空中肆虐。从燃烧的神庙中抢出的财宝、祭祀用的桌子、纯金的碗，以及从四面八方掠夺来的圣袍，敌人堆积着高高的战利品。孩子们和颤抖的母亲被驱赶成一条漫长而无尽的队伍。这就是最伟大的罗马诗人维吉尔，他写下这些文字时，距离汉尼拔那场针对罗马人的伟大战争——也就是本史诗系列的主题——已经过去了近两个世纪，
and a century or so after the final defeat of one of the protagonists in this story, the Mediterranean city of Carthage. And Tom, in that poem, the Aeneid, which is translated there by Robert Fagels, Virgil is taking us back, isn't he, to the legendary beginnings of Carthage. So shrouded in myth, the story of its founding. by the Phoenician Queen Dido, and the colonists from Phoenicia are laboring to build the new city. They're raising the walls, they're building the palaces and temples, the harbors that the Romans will later destroy. And at this point, this bedraggled group of refugees who've been shipwrecked off the African coast turn up. And these people are Trojans. They are.
距离这个故事中的主角之一——地中海城市迦太基——最终战败也过去了一个世纪左右。汤姆，在维吉尔的《埃涅阿斯纪》（由罗伯特·法格尔斯翻译）中，他把我们带回了迦太基传说中的起源，不是吗？迦太基的建立故事笼罩在神话之中，由腓尼基女王狄多建立，来自腓尼基的殖民者们正努力建造这座新城市。他们筑起城墙，建造宫殿和神庙，以及后来被罗马人摧毁的港口。就在这时，这群在非洲海岸遭遇海难、衣衫褴褛的难民出现了。这些人是特洛伊人。确实如此。
So they are, as you say, refugees from the sack of Troy by the Greeks. and the man speaking the lines that you read so powerfully is their leader, a prince called Eeneas, who is the son of Venus, the goddess of love and beauty. And Eneas, in that passage, is describing what it had been like to live through the destruction of Troy to watch its topless towers consumed by fire. And he is giving this account at a great feast that has been held in his honour by Dido, because she has fallen in love with Aeneas. And we talked about this in the very first episode that we did on Carthage.
正如你所说，他们是希腊人洗劫特洛伊后的难民。而你刚才有力地朗读那些台词的人，正是他们的领袖，一位名叫埃涅阿斯的王子，他是爱与美之女神维纳斯的儿子。在这一段中，埃涅阿斯正在描述经历特洛伊毁灭、看着它那高耸的塔楼被大火吞噬是什么样的感受。他是在狄多为他举办的一场盛大宴会上讲述这段经历的，因为狄多已经爱上了埃涅阿斯。我们在关于迦太基的第一集里谈到过这一点。
I mean, about 400 years ago. Actually, I think it was episode 421. And people who listen to that may remember what happens next after this feast. Because Aeneas and Ido go out hunting. There's a storm. They take shelter in a cave. And while they're in the cave, the earth moves. and Dido, although not Aeneas, assumes from this point on that they are now man and wife.
我是说，大约400年前。其实，我想那是第421集。听过那一集的人可能还记得宴会之后发生了什么。因为埃涅阿斯和狄多出去打猎。遇到了一场暴风雨。他们在山洞里避雨。当他们在洞里时，大地颤动。狄多，虽然埃涅阿斯没有，但从那一刻起就认为他们已经是夫妻了。
The problem for Dido is that Eneas has this destiny that has been plotted out for him by the gods, and specifically by Jupiter, the king of the gods. And this destiny is that Eneas has to sail to Italy and found a town there that in due course will result in the founding of Rome. And so Jupiter sends Mercury the messenger of the gods down to Aeneas and says, you know, stop hanging around with this Carthaginian woman. Get on, go and found Rome. And Ineus is very obedient to the will of the gods. And so he dumped Dido and he sails away from Carthage for Italy. And Dido is so distraught at being portrayed like this that she stabs herself to death with Aeneas's sword. But not before she has called
狄多的问题在于，埃涅阿斯有着众神，特别是众神之王朱庇特为他规划好的命运。这个命运就是埃涅阿斯必须航行到意大利，并在那里建立一座城镇，最终导致罗马的建立。于是朱庇特派众神的信使墨丘利下凡对埃涅阿斯说，你知道，别再和这个迦太基女人鬼混了。快走，去建立罗马。而埃涅阿斯非常顺从神的旨意。于是他抛弃了狄多，从迦太基航行前往意大利。狄多因被这样背叛而悲痛欲绝，用埃涅阿斯的剑自杀了。但在那之前，她曾呼唤
for her descendants to nurture an undying hatred for the descendants of Ineus. Shore clash with shore, sea against sea and sword against sword. This is my curse. War between all our peoples, all their children. Endless war. That's her curse, isn't it? And that's how it all begins. So she summons a demon to rise up from her bones, an avenger still unknown, to stalk the descendants of Aeneas, and to hunt them down with her. fire and iron. And Tom, who is this demon? Well, I mean, every Roman reading the Nied when it came out in the age of Augustus knew exactly who was meant. It was Hannibal, Hannibal Barker, that great military genius whose career we've been describing in our previous episodes,
她的后代要对埃涅阿斯的后代怀有永恒的仇恨。岸对岸，海对海，剑对剑。这就是我的诅咒。我们所有的人民，所有的孩子，都要陷入战争。无尽的战争。那是她的诅咒，对吧？一切就是这样开始的。于是她召唤了一个恶魔从她的骨骸中升起，一个尚不为人知的复仇者，去追踪埃涅阿斯的后代，用她的火与铁去猎杀他们。汤姆，这个恶魔是谁？嗯，我是说，每一个在奥古斯都时代读到《埃涅阿斯纪》的罗马人都确切地知道指的是谁。那就是汉尼拔，汉尼拔·巴卡，那位我们在前几集里描述过其职业生涯的伟大军事天才，
who for almost two decades had indeed fought the Romans with fire and iron. Now Hannibal, as we heard in our last episode, ends up this hunted fugitive, this defeated fugitive, kills himself in 183 BC. But it's the measure of the shock he had given Rome and of the terror that he had inspired in Roman hearts that still more than a century and a half after his death in the age of Augustus, you know, when the Roman Empire stands splendid and without a conceivable rival on the face of the planet, Hannibal continues to haunt the memory of the Romans. And so I think it's not hard to imagine what a bogey man he must have seemed to Romans who had lived through his invasion of Italy and who were born in the generation or two after the Great War that he
他确实在近二十年里用火与铁与罗马人作战。现在，正如我们在上一集听到的，汉尼拔最终成了一个被追捕的逃亡者，一个战败的逃亡者，于公元前183年自杀。但他给罗马带来的震撼，以及他在罗马人心中激起的恐惧，其程度之深，以至于在他死后一个半世纪多的奥古斯都时代，你知道，当罗马帝国在地球上屹立辉煌且没有可想见的对手时，汉尼拔依然萦绕在罗马人的记忆中。所以我认为不难想象，对于那些经历过他入侵意大利、并且出生在他对罗马人发动那场伟大战争之后一两代的人来说，他一定显得像个恶魔。
had prosecuted against the Romans. So that means that even though Carthage has been defeated and forced to accept a punitive peace deal, the memory of Hannibal and of Carthage's assault on Italy means that for the Romans, in their decades after victory, Carthage remains the supreme enemy. You know, is that, would I be going too far to say there's still a sense of unfinished business for the Romans? Completely, completely. Listeners may remember that in our previous series, we talked about Hannibal's preparations for the invasion of Italy in 218.
所以这意味着，尽管迦太基已经被击败并被迫接受了一项惩罚性的和平协议，但对汉尼拔和迦太基袭击意大利的记忆意味着，对于罗马人来说，在胜利后的几十年里，迦太基仍然是头号敌人。你知道，如果我说罗马人仍然有一种未竟事业的感觉，会不会太夸张了？完全不会，完全不会。听众可能还记得，在我们之前的系列节目中，我们谈到了汉尼拔在公元前218年为入侵意大利所做的准备。
And he has a dream. And in that dream, he sees a giant serpent that is following in his weight. as he invades Italy. And this serpent, quote, causing massive destruction to trees and bushes, a deafening thunderstorm following in its wake. And a god then explains to him what this serpent is. This serpent is Hannibal himself. And so the dream is pretending what the Romans called the Vastatio Italia, the destruction of Italy. And that is exactly what Hannibal had inflicted on Italy. So, monstrous, casualty figures, hundreds of thousands of people dead, fields, vineyards, orchards, going up in flames year after year after year. And nothing like it had remotely been experienced
他做了一个梦。在梦中，他看到一条巨大的毒蛇跟在他入侵意大利的足迹后面。这条毒蛇，引用原文，“对树木和灌木造成了巨大的破坏，身后跟着震耳欲聋的雷雨。”然后一位神向他解释了这条蛇是什么。这条蛇就是汉尼拔本人。所以这个梦预示了罗马人所说的“意大利的蹂躏”（Vastatio Italiae）。而这正是汉尼拔对意大利所造成的。如此惊人的伤亡数字，成千上万的人死亡，田野、葡萄园、果园年复一年地陷入火海。而这在两三代人里，罗马人或意大利人民从未经历过类似的事情。
by the Romans or the peoples of Italy, you know, for two or three generations, there hadn't been anything like this. And today there is considerable debate among historians about how bad the damage inflicted by Hannibal on Italy actually was. So opinions range from completely apocalyptic to merely, you know, pretty devastating. Right. But however bad it was, what mattered was that the Romans in the wake of Hannibal's war remembered it as complete devastation. So to quote Simon Hornblower on this, I mean, he's absolutely right.
今天，历史学家们对于汉尼拔对意大利造成的破坏到底有多严重存在相当大的争论。所以观点从完全的末日景象到仅仅是“相当具有破坏性”不等。没错。但无论它有多严重，重要的是，在汉尼拔战争之后，罗马人将其记忆为彻底的蹂躏。引用西蒙·霍恩布洛尔的话，他是完全正确的。
The trauma of Hannibal's lengthy presence, however great or small, the actual damage he wrought, will not have been easily forgotten. To that extent, Hannibal's dream may have been a true prophecy. perceptions are a kind of reality. I mean, we know that throughout history. And the Romans, I mean, the damage that the Carthaginians have inflicted is so deeply embedded in the Roman imagination. So the Romans come to talk about the Carthaginians, they use these expressions, Punica Fides, punica frouse. The idea that the Carthaginians are the embodiments, almost the linguistic embodiments of cruelty and deceit and infidelity and fraud and all of these kinds of things. And the
汉尼拔长期存在所带来的创伤，无论他造成的实际破坏是大是小，都不会轻易被遗忘。从这个程度上说，汉尼拔的梦可能是一个真实的预言。感知是一种现实。我的意思是，我们纵观历史都知道这一点。而罗马人，迦太基人造成的破坏深深地植根于罗马人的想象中。所以当罗马人谈论迦太基人时，他们使用这些表达，“布匿人的诚信”（Punica Fides），“布匿人的欺诈”（Punica Fraus）。认为迦太基人几乎是残忍、欺骗、背信弃义和欺诈的化身，所有这些东西。而
Carthaginians come to assume this almost kind of demonic place in the Roman imagination. Yeah, I mean, I think if you think about how the British view of the Germans in the wake of the First World War and even more the Second World War, there is something of that, the way that the Romans view the Carthaginians. And people who've listened to this series may well feel that this is a bit rich, because the Romans as well have been known to display cruelty and deceit and treachery and so on. But that doesn't really matter because the Romans felt what they felt. And this wasn't just a kind of widespread loathing of the Carthaginians,
迦太基人在罗马人的想象中占据了这种近乎恶魔般的地位。是的，我的意思是，如果你想想英国人在第一次世界大战甚至第二次世界大战后对德国人的看法，罗马人看待迦太基人的方式也有类似之处。听过这个系列节目的人可能会觉得这有点过分，因为罗马人也以表现出残忍、欺骗和背叛等行为而闻名。但这并不重要，因为罗马人有他们的感受。这不仅仅是对迦太基人普遍的厌恶，
but something more, a kind of biding fear that was ultimately irrational. Well, irrational because the Carthaginians had been completely beaten. Yeah, you know, completely smashed. It is so clear that the days of Carthage as a great power are finished because the terms that the Romans had imposed on Carthage in the war, wake of the defeat of Hannibal had been intended to cripple her forever. So just to remind listeners of what those terms were, a devastating indemnity, payable in installments over the course of 50 years, designed to kneecap Carthage's economy. The loss of all her overseas territories. Carthage had ruled
而是一种更深的东西，一种最终是非理性的、挥之不去的恐惧。嗯，非理性是因为迦太基人已经被彻底击败了。是的，你知道，彻底粉碎了。迦太基作为大国统治的日子已经结束了，这一点非常清楚，因为罗马人在汉尼拔战败后强加给迦太基的条款旨在永远削弱她。为了提醒听众这些条款是什么：一笔毁灭性的赔款，分50年支付，旨在废掉迦太基的经济。失去所有海外领土。迦太基曾经统治过
a great empire, you know, Sicily, Spain, whatever, all gone. Once she had been the greatest naval power in the Western Mediterranean. Her fleet is now limited to 10 warships. And her foreign policy is directly under the control of Rome, which means that she cannot go to war without Roman permission. So at the same time of the Romans have done that, so they've, Carthage has been kneecapped by all this, but on the western flank of Carthage, so that's, we're still in North Africa, we've got this character that we talked about before. Massini, Nisa, who is Numidian, and he's an old pal of Scipio Africanus, and he has basically been set up as a counterbalance to the Carthaginians, hasn't he? So he's a great pal of the Romans. He is constantly
一个伟大的帝国，你知道，西西里、西班牙等等，全都没了。她曾经是西地中海最强大的海军力量。她的舰队现在被限制为10艘战舰。她的外交政策直接受罗马控制，这意味着没有罗马的许可，她不能发动战争。与此同时，罗马人做了这些，所以迦太基被这一切废掉了，但在迦太基的西侧，也就是我们还在北非，我们有之前谈到的那个角色。马西尼萨，他是努米底亚人，他是大西庇阿的老朋友，他基本上被设定为迦太基人的制衡力量，不是吗？所以他是罗马人的好朋友。他不断地
kind of biting off bits of Carthage's sort of hinterland, so they're kind of, I don't know, the olive groves of North Africa and so on. Yeah, he's kind of nibbling away at them all the time. Yeah, and he's, there are constant kind of border disputes and whatnot. And basically the Numidians they're eroding Carthage's heartland year on year. Yeah, and for Massanissa, I mean, this is the servant turning on the master, because the Numidians had been a subject to Carthage. And so by salami slicing Carthage's territory, I mean, he's getting his own back on, you know, the old imperial mistress.
蚕食迦太基的腹地，比如北非的橄榄园等等。是的，他一直在一点点啃食它们。是的，而且不断有各种边界争端之类的。基本上，努米底亚人年复一年地侵蚀着迦太基的心脏地带。是的，对于马西尼萨来说，这就是仆人反抗主人，因为努米底亚人曾经是迦太基的臣民。所以通过像切萨拉米香肠一样切掉迦太基的领土，他是在向这位旧日的帝国女主人报复。
And so the poor Carthaginians, they can't really do anything about this because they're not allowed to fight Massanissa off. And so all they can really do is send embassies to Rome. complaining about these encroachments by the Nimidians. But obviously, Massinissa, he's an ally of the Roman people. He can send embassies of his own and be assured of getting heard. So in 171, for instance, Carthaginians have gone to Rome to complain. Massinissa sends his own son.
所以可怜的迦太基人，他们对此真的无能为力，因为他们不被允许反击马西尼萨。所以他们唯一能做的就是向罗马派遣使团，抱怨努米底亚人的这些侵占。但显然，马西尼萨是罗马人民的盟友。他可以派遣自己的使团，并确保得到倾听。所以例如在公元前171年，迦太基人去罗马投诉。马西尼萨派了他自己的儿子。
And this son of Massanissa's is, he knows exactly how to play the Romans. So he's endlessly going on about how the Carthaginians are treacherous and deceitful, beware of punic deceit, all this kind of stuff. And so the Carthaginians don't get justice. And the Romans ignore Carthaginian complaints not just because they are pro-Numidian, but also to reiterate, because they are genuinely fearful that Carthage might make a comeback. And so they feel that she has to, you know, her territory has to constantly be eroded. But this is mad. I mean, there's no prospect of Carthage coming back. Well, to give people a sense of the map, so we're three decades on after the defeat of Hannibal and the Romans power is spreading across the Mediterranean. So to give
而马西尼萨的这个儿子，他非常清楚如何操纵罗马人。所以他不断地谈论迦太基人是多么背信弃义和狡诈，要提防“布匿人的欺诈”，所有这些东西。所以迦太基人得不到正义。罗马人无视迦太基人的投诉，不仅因为他们亲努米底亚，还因为要重申，他们确实担心迦太基可能会卷土重来。所以他们觉得她必须，你知道，她的领土必须不断被侵蚀。但这太疯狂了。我的意思是，迦太基根本没有卷土重来的希望。嗯，为了让人们对地图有个概念，我们在汉尼拔战败后已经过了三十年，罗马的力量正在横跨地中海扩张。所以举个例子，
the example of Spain, we talked a lot about Spain. Spain with its mineral wealth have been so important to Carthaginian power. But the Romans have basically formalized their control of the coastal bits of Spain. They've conquered from Carthage. They've organized them into provinces. They're pushing inland in North Africa. So we've obviously talked about Numidia. New Media is basically a Roman client state. I mean, in many ways, Carthage is a Roman client state as well because it's subject to all the demands of the peace treaty. We talked last time about Greece. You know, we're getting into the kind of remnants of Alexander the Great Empire now.
西班牙，我们谈了很多关于西班牙的事。拥有矿产资源的西班牙对迦太基的力量非常重要。但罗马人基本上已经正式控制了西班牙的沿海地区。他们从迦太基手中征服了这些地方。他们将它们组织成行省。他们在北非向内陆推进。所以我们显然谈到了努米底亚。努米底亚基本上是一个罗马附庸国。我的意思是，在许多方面，迦太基也是一个罗马附庸国，因为它受和平条约的所有要求限制。我们上次谈到了希腊。你知道，我们现在进入了亚历山大大帝帝国的残余部分。
So in Greece, the Romans have been launching these devastating strikes. They've humbled the heirs of Alexander, the Macedonian kings. We talked about that last time. The legions have defeated the Macedonian phalanx. And although the Romans are not ruling Macedonia or Greece direct. Roman primacy, Roman control is basically acknowledged, isn't it, throughout Greece? Yeah, and I think the Romans feel that if their strategic demands require the Greeks to knuckle down and kind of surrender chunks of territory or autonomy or whatever, then they have to do it.
所以在希腊，罗马人一直在发动毁灭性的打击。他们羞辱了亚历山大的继承者，马其顿国王。我们上次谈到了这一点。军团击败了马其顿方阵。虽然罗马人没有直接统治马其顿或希腊。罗马的至高无上，罗马的控制基本上在整个希腊都被承认了，不是吗？是的，我认为罗马人觉得如果他们的战略需求要求希腊人屈服并交出部分领土或自治权什么的，那么他们就必须这样做。
And there's perhaps slight element of Donald Trump's attitude to Greenland about all this. and increasingly, the more that Greece and the Balkans kind of have to do what the Romans say, the Romans decide what there's no point in allowing the Macedonians to have any autonomy at all. I mean, we might as well snuff that out. So in June 168, the legions once again meet with a Macedonian phalanx, and it's fought in a great battle on the Macedonian coast, a place called Pidna. and the guy in command of the Roman legions at this battle is called Imelius Paulus. And if that sounds familiar, then it's because he is the son of the Imelius Paulus
关于这一切，可能有一点唐纳德·特朗普对待格陵兰岛的态度。而且，随着希腊和巴尔干半岛越来越不得不听从罗马人的话，罗马人决定，允许马其顿人拥有任何自治权都没有意义。我的意思是，我们还不如把它掐灭。所以公元前168年6月，军团再次与马其顿方阵相遇，战斗发生在马其顿海岸一个叫皮德纳的地方。在这场战斗中指挥罗马军团的人叫埃米利乌斯·保卢斯。如果这听起来很熟悉，那是因为他是那个在坎尼——汉尼拔的伟大胜利——中阵亡的埃米利乌斯·保卢斯的儿子。
who had died at Can I, Hannibal's great victory. And Amelius Paulus at Pidna, he confessed that the advance of the Macedonian phalanx was such a terrifying sight that he had briefly dreaded that he might suffer a defeat similar to that, suffered by his father. but in the event he wins this spectacular, utterly crushing victory. So the legionaries, you know, they're much more flexible, much more mobile, and they're able to infiltrate the phalanx through gaps that open up in its ranks. And then it's just a massacre.
而皮德纳的埃米利乌斯·保卢斯承认，马其顿方阵的推进是如此可怕的景象，以至于他曾短暂地担心自己可能会遭受与其父亲类似的失败。但最终他赢得了这场壮观的、彻底的压倒性胜利。所以军团士兵，你知道，他们灵活得多，机动性强得多，他们能够通过方阵行列中出现的缺口渗透进去。然后这就成了一场屠杀。
The people in the phalanx have these huge long spears, so they're hapless against the gladius, the stabbing sword that the Romans are using. And the whole battlefield just becomes this great sea of blood and viscera. All their guts are kind of, you know, the Macedonian guts are spilling out. The Macedonian king is captured, he's deposed, and ends up being led through the streets of Rome in Paulus's triumph. And Macedon itself, the monarchy is abolished and it is divided up into these kind of four petty cantons under dodgy little republics. And this is obviously a recipe for instability, but that for the Romans is precisely the point. They're not there to administer direct rule, but what they do want is,
方阵中的人拿着这些巨大的长矛，所以在罗马人使用的短剑（gladius）面前他们毫无还手之力。整个战场变成了一片血与内脏的海洋。他们所有的肠子，你知道，马其顿人的肠子都流了出来。马其顿国王被俘，被废黜，最终在保卢斯的凯旋式中被带过罗马的街道。马其顿本身的君主制被废除，它被分裂成四个由不可靠的小共和国组成的卑微州。这显然是动荡的根源，但对罗马人来说，这正是重点。他们不是去进行直接统治，但他们想要的是，
Macedon left both submissive and impotent and that is what these reforms do And then the same thing goes for other parts of southern Balkans Doesn't it? So Epirus is sacked That's in the west that's towards sort of northern northwestern Greece Albania Powis takes more than 100,000 slaves there
马其顿既顺从又无能，而这些改革正是为了达到这个目的。然后其他南巴尔干地区也是一样，不是吗？所以伊庇鲁斯被洗劫了。那是在西部，靠近希腊西北部，阿尔巴尼亚。保卢斯在那里抓了超过10万名奴隶。
And then in Greece itself they basically take a thousand So bigwigs hostage from various cities They take them all back to Italy and these guys had been seen as two pro-Macedonian, two independent-minded. And Tom, you've got a nice analogy here, which I'd share your analogy with us. Yeah. Well, to pursue the Donald Trump analogy, it's as though he were to invade Europe and take back as hostages, you know, a raft of Eurocrats from Brussels, regulators of American
然后在希腊本身，他们基本上从各个城市抓了一千名大人物作为人质。他们把他们全部带回意大利，这些人被认为太亲马其顿，太有独立思想了。汤姆，你这里有一个很好的类比，我想请你分享一下。嗯，为了追求唐纳德·特朗普的类比，这就像他入侵欧洲并带回人质，你知道，一大批来自布鲁塞尔的欧洲官僚、美国社交媒体公司的监管者，显然还有英国广播公司的总干事，他们都会被带回华盛顿并作为人质关押。有没有现任政府的人，你希望看到被三角洲部队作为人质带回华盛顿的？肯定有吧。无可奉告。所以所有这些希腊人质都被带回去了。其中有一个来自阿卡迪亚的希腊人，我们在整个系列中提到过很多次他的名字。
social media companies, and obviously the Director General of the BBC, and they would all be taken back to Washington and kept as hostages. Are there any people from the current government? you'd like to see taken as hostages by Delta Force back to Washington. Surely there must be. No comment. So all these Greek hostages are taken back. And among them is a Greek from Arcadia, whose name we have been mentioning quite a lot throughout this series.
那就是波利比乌斯，他将成为罗马在地中海崛起为霸主的伟大历史学家。波利比乌斯历史的主题，他设定好了。它是关于意大利和非洲的事务是如何与亚洲和希腊的事务交织在一起的，所有事物都一致指向一个单一的终点。而那个单一的终点就是建立一个罗马帝国（Imperium），一个横跨地中海的罗马帝国。波利比乌斯最终在罗马做了17年的被拘留者。所以这就是他如何获得对罗马政治、罗马宪法安排、罗马事务的不可思议的熟悉程度，并且他能够采访汉尼拔战争的退伍军人，那些在战争中担任领导角色的人。但从长远来看，波利比乌斯在罗马建立的最有用的联系并不是汉尼拔战争的退伍军人，而是这个十几岁的家伙，他非常早熟，非常聪明，并且有着绝对闪耀的血统。
And that is Polybius, who will become the great historian of Rome's rise to dominance in the Mediterranean. And the theme of Polybius's history, he kind of sets it out. It's how the affairs of Italy and of Africa came to be interwoven with those of Asia and of Greece, and all things point in concert to a single end. And that single end is the establishment of a Roman Imperium, a Roman Empire over the Mediterranean. And Polybius would end up spending 17 years as a detainee in Rome. And so this is how he came by his incredible familiarity with Romanians. in politics, Roman constitutional arrangements, Roman affairs, and he is able to interview veterans
因为这个人是皮德纳战役获胜者埃米利乌斯·保卢斯的儿子，所以他是坎尼战役中阵亡的埃米利乌斯·保卢斯的孙子。他也是击败汉尼拔的大西庇阿的养孙。在罗马，收养是非常严肃的事情。所以这意味着他基本上被罗马人视为大西庇阿的孙子。
of the war against Hannibal, people who had taken leading roles in that war. But in the long run, the most useful contact that Polybius makes in Rome isn't a kind of veteran of the war against Hannibal, but this guy still in his teens, he's very precocious, very brilliant, and has an absolutely kind of glittering pedigree. because this man is the son of the Emilius Paulus, who had won at Pidna, so he's therefore the grandson of the Emilius Paulus who had died at Can I. He is also the adoptive grandson of Scipio-Africanus, the man who had defeated Hannibal. And in Rome, adoption is taken very seriously. So that means that he is basically seen by the Romans as the grandson of Scipio-Africanus.
因为他是埃米利乌斯·保卢斯的儿子，他被称为埃米利亚努斯。所以是小西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）。而且你知道，他是汉尼拔伟大征服者完全合格的孙子。当他只有17岁时，他曾随父亲在皮德纳作战，战功赫赫。他后来去了西班牙，赢得了一枚军事桂冠，基本上相当于维多利亚十字勋章，因为他是第一个翻过敌城城墙的人。同时，像大西庇阿一样，他是一位希腊文化的热情爱好者，一位伟大的学者，实际上这就是他通过借阅一些书籍和一般的文学聊天与波利比乌斯接触的方式。所以，小西庇阿和波利比乌斯，就像你和塔比（Tabby）在你们即将推出的播客中要做的那样。那个类比里谁是塔比？我是小西庇阿，对吧？嗯，小西庇阿年轻得多，所以可能是塔比。
Because he is the son of Amelius-Palus, he's called Amelianus. So Scipio-Amelianus. and you know he is a completely worthy grandson of the great conqueror of Hannibal when he was only 17 he had fought with his father at pittner covered himself in glory he'd then gone to spain he had won a military crown so basically the equivalent of a victoria cross by being the first over the wall of an enemy city at the same time like scipia africanus he is a great enthusiast for Greek culture a great scholar, and actually this is how he'd come into contact with Polybius through the loan of some books and general literary chat. So, Scipio, Emilianus and Polybius, it's like you and Tabby will be doing on your forthcoming podcast. Who's tabby in that analogy? I'm Scipio Emilianus, right? Well, Scipio Emilianus is much younger, so it's probably tabby.
是的，但这是关于魅力，不是吗？你是这个希腊人质。不，绝对不是。好吧，让我们回到迦太基。所以，小西庇阿，罗马历史上的多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sambrook）。他余下历史的塔比·西雷特（Tabby Siret）。他怎么看迦太基？因为他是基本上击败迦太基的那个人（大西庇阿）的养孙。
Yeah, but it's about charisma, isn't it? You are this Greek hostage. No, absolutely not. Right, let's get back to Carthage. So, Scipio Emilianus, the Dominic Sambrook of Roman history. The Tabi Siret of the rest of his history. What does he make of Carthage? Because he's the adoptive grandson of the bloke who basically defeated it.
所以他觉得他和迦太基有未竟的事业吗？他想做同样的事吗？实际上，似乎并非如此。我认为大西庇阿，因为他是强迫迦太基人接受条款并让他们接受这些条款的人。他随后对迦太基感到某种责任，因为这有点像赞助人与客户的关系。
So does he feel that he has unfinished business with Carthage? Does he want to do the same? Actually, it seems not. I think that Scipio Africanus, because he was the guy who had forced terms on the Carthaginians and got them to accept these terms. He then felt a certain kind of responsibility towards Carthage, because it's a bit like a patron with a client.
那是对罗马贵族非常重要的关系。我认为大西庇阿，你知道，他认真对待了这一点。所以，例如，只要汉尼拔还在迦太基，在罗马的大西庇阿就一直支持汉尼拔。我认为西庇阿王朝的所有成员都分担了这种义务。我们可以从波利比乌斯那里看到这一点，他显然深受西庇阿王朝思想的影响。
That is a relationship that is very important to the Roman aristocracy. And I think that Scipio Afrikanus, you know, he took this seriously. So, for instance, for as long as Hannibal was in Carthage, Scipio Africanus back in Rome had had Hannibal's back. And I think all the kind of the various members of Scipio's dynasty, they share in this obligation. So we can see this from Polybius, who is obviously very influenced by what the Scipio dynasty think.
所以他总是描述迦太基人如何去罗马抱怨马西尼萨切掉他们领土的一部分。而波利比乌斯，我的意思是，他强调这些投诉是正当的。据推测，在这样说时，他是在采纳他的西庇阿赞助人的观点。但我认为公平地说，这在罗马是一个少数派立场。有一个人特别认为，任何试图淡化对待迦太基的严厉程度的行为本质上都是一种叛国。
So he's always describing how the Carthaginians are going to Rome to complain about Massanissa slicing off bits of their territory. And Polybius, I mean, he emphasizes that these complaints are just. And presumably in saying that, he is picking up on the opinion of his scipionic patrons. But I think it's fair to say that this. This in Rome is a minority position. And there is one person in particular who views any kind of attempt to water down the harshness with which Carthage is treated as essentially a form of treason.
这就是大西庇阿的宿敌。所以我们再次在上一集遇到了他，马尔库斯·波尔基乌斯·加图（Marcus Porcius Cato）。是的。到这个时候，他刚满80岁，但他依然像以往一样坚硬和强硬。所以那种，你知道，他那红色的头发已经没了。他现在可怕地秃顶，有很多鱼尾纹和赘肉。他是一个可怕的人。我讨厌他。我觉得加图是一个非常令人不快的人。嗯，我认为讨厌他有充分的理由，正如我们随着这一集的进展所看到的那样。
And this is the old enemy of Scipio-Africanus. So again, we met in the last episode, Marcus Porzius Cato. Yeah. Who by this point, he's just turned 80, but he is as flinty and as hardcore. as ever. So that kind of, you know, that ginger hair that he had has gone. He's now terrifyingly bald and got lots of crow feet and jowls. He's a terrifying man. I hate him. I find Cato such an unpleasant person. Well, I think there are good reasons for hating him as we will see as this episode progresses.
所以加图被派往迦太基。我的意思是，在所有人中，他去了迦太基，在公元前152年，去调查迦太基人和努米底亚人马西尼萨之间的又一次争吵。马西尼萨到这个时候也非常老了。应该说一下。当加图到达迦太基时，他被他所看到的景象惊呆了，因为基本上他以为迦太基人会像阴沟里的狗一样生活，他们的城市已成废墟。
So Cato was sent, he goes to Carthage. I mean, of all people to go, he goes to Carthage and 152, doesn't he, to investigate yet another spat between. the Carthaginians and the Numidians, Massinisa. Massinisa, by this point, is also very old. It should just be said. And when Cato gets to Carthage, he is horrified by what he sees, because basically he had assumed that the Carthaginians would be living like dogs in the gutter, their city in ruins.
但实际上，迦太基人，公平地说，他们已经把自己重新站了起来，城市实际上又做得相当不错了。加图一点也不喜欢这样。他们没有帝国要管理。他们没有战争要打。所以迦太基人能够把所有的精力都集中在发财上。所以，我的意思是，为了追求另一个类比，这有点像第二次世界大战后的西德。他们不被允许拥有军队什么的。
But actually, the Carthaginians, fair play to them, they've dragged themselves back upright, and the city is actually doing quite well again. And Cato doesn't like this at all. They don't have an empire to run. They don't have wars to fight. And so the Carthaginians have been able to focus all their energies on getting rich. So again, I mean, to pursue another analogy, it's a bit like West Germany after the Second World War. They're not allowed to have an army or anything.
所以他们只能专注于发明电视之类的东西。那个旧的迦太基-波恩平行线。所以迦太基人实际上做得非常好。尽管罗马人试图废掉其经济，但经济正在蓬勃发展。他们有这个腹地。努米底亚人可能在蚕食，但迦太基仍然控制着大部分。它非常肥沃，非常富有。迦太基有巨大的粮仓。它基本上已经成为西地中海的粮仓，这是它在随后的罗马历史中将扮演的角色。
So they can just focus on kind of inventing televisions and stuff. That old Carthage Bonn parallel. So the Carthaginians are actually doing very well. And despite the attempts of the Romans to kneecap its economy, the economy is booming. They have this hinterland. the Namidians may be snipping bits off, but Carthage still controls most of it. It's very fertile, very rich. Carthage has massive grain silos. It's essentially become the breadbasket of the Western Mediterranean, which is a role that it will play throughout the history, subsequent history of the Roman
他们升级了他们的港口，他们有这个内船坞，有170艘船的泊位。加图显然对此非常怀疑。他们为什么需要170艘船的泊位？他还注意到仓库里堆积着成堆的木材。所以他在想，你知道，这些木材是用于建造商船的吗？还是迦太基人计划重新启动一支战舰舰队？加图毕竟是加图，他显然往最坏处想。他回到罗马，确信迦太基人正在为复仇做准备。他站在元老院前。
Empire. They have upgraded their harbors, and they have this inner dockyard, which has berths for 170 ships. And Cato is obviously very suspicious of this. Why do they need births for 170 ships? And he also notices storehouses in which there are piled great mounds of timber. And so he's thinking, you know, is this timber for the construction of merchant shipping? Or are the Carthaginians planning to reactivate a war fleet? And Cato being Cato, he obviously assumes the worst. And he returns to Rome convinced that the Carthaginians are preparing for vengeance. And he stands before the Senate.
他抖开托加长袍的褶皱，从他的长袍里掉落了一个无花果。加图弯下腰，把它举起来，邀请他的元老同僚们欣赏它。它非常饱满，非常漂亮，显然仍然非常新鲜。然后加图透露，这个无花果来自迦太基，正如他指出的，距离罗马仅三天的航程。他的信息是双重的。首先，迦太基作为一个大国回来了。
and he shakes out the folds of his toga and from his toga there drops a fig. Cato bends down, he holds it up and he invites his fellow senators to admire it. It's very plump, it's very beautiful, it's clearly still very fresh. And Cato then reveals that this fig had come from Carthage, as he points out, a mere three days sail from Rome. And his message is twofold. Firstly, Carthage is back as a great power.
是的。但其次，假设发动第三次布匿战争，一场针对迦太基的灭绝战争。那么北非所有目前由迦太基统治的土地，
Yeah. But secondly, suppose a third Punic war were to be launched, a war of annihilation against Carthage. Then all those lands in North Africa, currently ruled by Carthage,
都将成为罗马的。所以从那时起，每当加图在元老院站起来，他给我们做了一个演讲。他每次演讲的结尾都一样，不是吗？他做出同样紧急的、响亮的声明。更重要的是，我的意思是，这对他的听众来说一定非常无聊。他每次都说同样的话。无论如何，他说，更重要的是，我认为迦太基必须被摧毁。我的意思是，多米尼克，你说这对他的听众来说一定很无聊。我一点也不这么认为。
would become Rome's. And so from that point onwards, whenever Cato stands up in the Senate, and he gives us a speech. He ends every speech the same way, doesn't he? He makes the same urgent, sort of resounding pronouncement. What is more? I mean, it must be extremely boring for his listeners. He says the same thing every time. Anyway, he says, what is more? I think that Carthage must be destroyed. I mean, Dominant, you say it must be boring for his listeners. I don't think so at all.
他的演讲不一定都是关于迦太基的。是的。但他总是发表这个评论。所以你在听它，你有点在等待它。他又要怎么扯到迦太基？他会随意地提到它。但这是一种鼓点，不是吗？如果罗马人喜欢一件事，那就是战争的鼓点。所以我认为他本质上是在煽动一种战争狂热。而这种他所做的声明，在每次演讲结束时，
His speeches are not necessarily about Carthage. Yeah. But he always makes this comment. And so you're listening to it and you're kind of waiting for it. How is you going to get Carthagin again? He'll just mention it willy-nilly. But it is a kind of drumbeat, isn't it? And if there's one thing the Romans love, it's a drumbeat of war. So I think he is essentially kind of provoking a war fever. And this kind of statement that he's making, at the end of every speech,
“更重要的是，我认为迦太基必须被摧毁”，缩写。它已经成为所有拉丁语格言中最臭名昭著的一句。Carthago delenda est。迦太基必须被摧毁。所以最后的对抗和迦太基的灭绝舞台已经搭好了。休息后回来听这个非常悲伤的故事。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。
what is more, I think, that Carthage must be destroyed, abbreviated. It's become one of the most notorious of all Latin aphorisms. Cathago del. Lender est. Carthage must be destroyed. So the scene is set for the final confrontation and the annihilation of Carthage. Come back after the break for this very sad story. Welcome back to The Restis History.
那是公元前152年。而加图，这个罗马政治中脾气暴躁、可怜的老人，每个人都钦佩，或者至少很多人钦佩，因为他那种共和主义的节俭和那种炫耀性的、表演性的、清教徒式的道德，他现在正在呼吁彻底摧毁迦太基。汤姆，你在笔记里用了“种族灭绝”这个词。据推测，他不是在呼吁消灭
The year is 152 BC. And Cato, this crabby, miserable old man of Roman politics, who everybody admires, or at least a lot of people admire, for his sort of Republican austerity and his ostentatious, performative, puritanical morality, he is now calling for the total destruction of Carthage. Tom, you've got the word genocide in the notes. Presumably he's not calling for the extermination
每一个迦太基人。是城市而不是人民，还是我弄错了？我认为如果你说摧毁一座城市，你实际上是在说摧毁一个民族。摧毁一个民族的母城，实际上就是摧毁一个民族。所以我认为，我的意思是，这是时代错误，但我认为其中有那个因素。而且我认为人们应该意识到正在计划的事情，正在计划的事情的规模。
of every last Carthaginian. It's the city rather than the people, or have I got that wrong. I think if you're saying destroy a city, you are effectively saying destroy a people. To destroy the mother city of a people, effectively is to destroy a people. So I think it's, I mean, it's anachronistic, but I think there is that element in it. And I think that people should be aware of what is being planned, the scale of what is being planned.
我的意思是，这太可怕了。而且一些罗马人认为这很可怕，对吧？绝对是。罗马有元老反对加图。当然，其中许多人属于大西庇阿的王朝。其中一个人，一个叫西庇阿·纳西卡（Scipio Nasica）的家伙，他创造了自己的口号来反击加图的。所以他的是，Carthago servanda est，
I mean, it is horrific. And some of the Romans think it's horrific, right? Absolutely. There are senators in Rome who oppose Cato. And of course, many of these belong to the dynasty of Scipio-Africanus. and one of them, a guy called Scipio Nasica, he's coined his own catchphrase to counter Cato's. So his is, Cathago Savander-est,
迦太基必须被保留。现在，听众可能想知道，他想出这个口号的动机是什么？是因为他有一种人道感，对人权的关注吗？是因为他那种善良的深处吗？并不是。关注善良似乎并不是一个因素。
Carthage must be preserved. Now, listeners may be wondering, what's his motivation in coming up with this catchphrase? Is it because he has a sense of humanity, a concern for human rights? Is it from, you know, the depths of his kindness? It is not. A concern with being kind does not really seem to have been a factor.
那些反对对迦太基进行灭绝战争的人，他们的动机是一个世纪后一位希腊历史学家告诉我们的。根本上是罗马需要一个值得尊敬的敌人。因为让迦太基作为家门口的这个大恶魔让他们保持诚实。这让他们保持警惕。担心的是，如果你摧毁了迦太基，那么罗马人可能会变得颓废和自我放纵，如果他们不需要防范外部敌人，最终可能会自相残杀，所有这些，当然，在某种意义上确实发生了。所以很有可能那位希腊历史学家是在事后诸葛亮。我的意思是，你知道，不一定，但有可能。而且我确实认为很清楚，当时罗马元老院中罗马人焦虑的主要来源，
Those who are arguing against a war of annihilation against Carthage, their motivations were told by a Greek historian writing a century later. Fundamentally is that Rome needs a worthy enemy. Because having Carthage as this great bogey on their doorstep keeps them honest. It keeps them on their toes. And the worry is that if you destroy Carthage, then the Romans may become decadent and self-indulgent and may end up kind of turning on themselves if they don't have to guard against an outside enemy, all of which, of course, in a sense, does happen. And so it's more than possible that that Greek historian is writing with the benefit of hindsight. I mean, you know, not necessarily, but possible. And I do think it's clear that at the time, the chief source of anxiety for Romans in the Senate,
听着加图推动这场灭绝战争，实际上是他们担心违反他们与迦太基签署的条约，因为这会冒犯众神，给他们的城市带来神圣的愤怒。因为罗马人，他们认为自己是最虔诚的民族，当然他们也非常讲究法律。所以即使在他们攻击马其顿国王或抓捕希腊大人物作为人质时，他们总是需要感到他们在法律上是正当的。正如他们所见，他们没有做任何不值得或无端的事情。他们总是必须感到众神站在他们这一边。所以这就是元老院中大量人觉得他们在迦太基问题上所需要的。没有战争借口（Casus Belli），他们不能攻击迦太基。
listening to Cato, push for this war of annihilation, is actually that they're worried about breaking the treaty that they'd signed with Carthage, because this will then offend the gods and bring down divine anger on the head of their city. because the Romans, they saw themselves as being the most devout of peoples, and certainly they were kind of very legalistic. So even when they are attacking Macedonian kings or taking Greek bigwigs hostage, they always needed to feel that they were legally justified in what they were doing. They're not, as they see it, doing anything that is unmerited or unprovoked. They always have to feel that the gods are on their side. And so this is what large numbers in the Senate feel they need with regard to Carthage. They can't attack Carthage without Akazas Beli.
幸运的是，他们手头有一个，因为这就是马西尼萨。对。所以这个家伙一直在与迦太基人进行边界小规模冲突，攻击他们的农田，抢夺他们的橄榄园什么的。但如果你是加图或罗马的鹰派之一，这不是绝佳的机会吗？他就像弗拉基米尔·普京在乌克兰战争中基本上作为借口使用的乌克兰东部顿涅茨克和卢甘斯克的人民一样。是的。
And fortunately for them, they have one on hand because this is Massinissa. Right. So this bloke has been constantly having his border skirmishes with the Carthaginians and attacking their farmland and snatching their olive groves or whatever. But if you're Cato or one of the warhawks in Rome, isn't this the perfect opportunity? He's like the equivalent of the people in Donetsk and Luhansk in eastern Ukraine who Vladimir Putin used as a pretext basically for his war in Ukraine. Yes.
所以马西尼萨现在80多岁了，依然像以往一样贪婪。所以他的人继续对迦太基农村腹地的农场和庄园发动攻击，目的是占有它们。而在迦太基，现在人们对罗马是否会约束马西尼萨感到彻底绝望。这种绝望带来了比前一代更强硬的新领导人。这些人说，好吧，看，我们需要一个更强硬的外交政策。我们不能再这样下去了。所以公元前151年，无视他们在公元前201年与罗马签署的条约规定，迦太基人与马西尼萨开战了。他们没有得到罗马人的许可这样做。而对迦太基人来说，结果是，
And so Massinissa by now in his late 80s is as acquisitive as ever. And so his men continue to launch attacks on farms and estates in Carthage's rural hinterland with the aim of appropriating them. And in Carthage, there is now total despair that Rome will ever raise. rein massinissa in. And this despair brings new leaders to power who are much more hawkish than the previous generation. And these are men who are saying, well, look, we need a more assertive foreign policy. We cannot go on like this. So in 151, ignoring the prescriptions of the treaty that they had signed with Rome back in 201, the Carthaginians go to war with Massinissa. They do not have the permission of the Romans to do this. And the result for the Carthaginians,
因此，当时已年近九旬的马西尼萨依然贪得无厌。他的手下继续对迦太基农村腹地的农场和庄园发动袭击，企图将其据为己有。在迦太基，人们对罗马是否会出面约束马西尼萨彻底绝望了。这种绝望情绪将一批比前一代人更加强硬的领导人推上了权力舞台。这些人主张，我们需要采取更果断的外交政策，不能再这样下去了。于是，在公元前151年，迦太基人无视他们在公元前201年与罗马签署的条约规定，对马西尼萨发动了战争。他们并未获得罗马人的许可，而这对迦太基人来说，其结果是
unfortunately, is disaster. So Massinissa, he's now basically 90, but he's still in the saddle. He fights the Carthaginian army to a standstill near a town called Oroscopa, and he isolates them on a hill. They don't have any water. So they have no option but to surrender and submit to humiliating terms, which include, again, a kind of massive indemnity. which is bad enough, but the real disaster is the open goal, obviously, that the Carthaginians have now given to the war party in Rome, because Hawks there can now argue that Carthage is in breach of her treaty obligations and that therefore, if the Romans attack Carthage, the gods will be backing them. So that's everything they need. So now the Romans have their opportunity to launch their strike. And what is more, there are financial motives, aren't there? Because in 151, the, Carthaginians have paid off the very last instalments, basically of their reparations, their war indemnity. So there's going to be no more money coming to Rome from Carthage. If the Romans want the Carthaginian wealth, they have to go and seize it.
不幸的是，这是一场灾难。马西尼萨现在基本上已经90岁了，但他依然骑在马上。他在奥罗斯科帕（Oroscopa）附近的一个城镇将迦太基军队逼入绝境，并将他们围困在一座山上。他们没有任何水源，所以除了投降并接受屈辱的条款外别无选择，这些条款再次包括了巨额赔款。这已经够糟糕了，但真正的灾难显然是迦太基人现在给了罗马主战派一个绝佳的借口，因为那里的鹰派现在可以辩称迦太基违反了条约义务，因此，如果罗马人攻击迦太基，神灵将会支持他们。这就是他们所需要的一切。所以现在罗马人有了发动进攻的机会。而且，还有经济动机，不是吗？因为在公元前151年，迦太基人基本上已经支付了他们赔款（即战争赔偿金）的最后一期。所以罗马将不会再从迦太基得到任何钱了。如果罗马人想要迦太基的财富，他们就必须去夺取它。
So they've both got the kind of the diplomatic opportunity because there's business with Massinisa, but also now there is a very big financial incentive for greedy people in Rome to urge a war with Carthage. It's like these people who say, well, it's like, I don't know, Saddam Hussein is a bad man and there's a lot of oil in Iraq, you know, let's go in. Yeah, exactly. And so in 150, the Romans begin to mobilize for an invasion of Africa. And back in Carthage, understandably, the news of this throws the entire city into panic. And so they desperately try to appease the Romans. And they do this first of all by condemning the general who'd been defeated at Oroscopa to death. and it will not surprise regular listeners to this series to learn that the name of this general is of course
所以他们既有外交上的机会，因为有马西尼萨的事情，而且现在对于罗马那些贪婪的人来说，还有一个巨大的经济诱因去敦促与迦太基开战。这就像那些人说，嗯，我不知道，萨达姆·侯赛因是个坏人，伊拉克有很多石油，你知道，我们进去吧。是的，完全正确。因此在公元前150年，罗马人开始动员入侵非洲。而在迦太基，可以理解的是，这个消息让整个城市陷入了恐慌。于是他们拼命试图安抚罗马人。他们首先通过判处在奥罗斯科帕战败的将军死刑来做到这一点。对于本系列的常客来说，得知这位将军的名字当然不会感到惊讶，那就是
Hastrable, yet another Yelch, and then the Carthaginians send an embassy to Rome, basically to beg for mercy. And when they arrive there, they're appalled to discover that this Roman task force has already left and is in Sicily, so just across the sea from Carthage. And they also find Cato on absolutely top form.
哈斯德鲁巴（Hasdrubal），又一个耶尔奇（Yelch），然后迦太基人派遣使团前往罗马，基本上是去乞求宽恕。当他们到达那里时，他们震惊地发现这支罗马特遣部队已经出发并到达了西西里岛，也就是在迦太基对面的海域。他们还发现加图（Cato）正处于绝对的最佳状态。
So he gives a kind of zinger of a speech. what people can't be trusted to keep their treaties the Carthaginians what people are inveterate warmongers notorious for their cruelty the Carthaginians what people left Italy a smouldering wasteland the Carthaginians so still that harping on all the destruction that Hannibal had brought to Italy and when the Carthaginian envoys you know they beg to know how can we make amends I mean what can we do they receive this very menacingly Delphic response by satisfying the Roman people. But the Senate does not specify how this satisfaction can be obtained.
所以他发表了一番精彩的演讲。什么样的人不能被信任去遵守条约？迦太基人。什么样的人是根深蒂固的战争贩子，以残忍著称？迦太基人。什么样的人把意大利变成了一片闷烧的荒原？迦太基人。所以他仍然在喋喋不休地谈论汉尼拔给意大利带来的所有破坏。当迦太基使节乞求知道我们该如何弥补，我的意思是我们可以做什么时，他们得到了这个非常具有威胁性的德尔斐式的回应：通过满足罗马人民。但元老院并没有具体说明如何才能获得这种满足。
So let's take us to the next year, 12 months on. The Romans have landed in North Africa. They have established their base camp 30 miles northwest of Carthage. The Carthaginians sent envoys to try and negotiate with the Romans and what happens next? Well, they arrive at the Roman camp and as they approach there's this kind of great deafening blast of trumpets. And then they enter the camp and they are led past the massed ranks of the legions who are all drawn up and who are totally silent. I mean, it must have been terrifying. Ahead of them are the two consuls sat down on a podium and the Carthaginian envoys are brought before the consuls.
那么让我们进入下一年，12个月后。罗马人已经在北非登陆。他们在迦太基西北30英里处建立了基地营地。迦太基人派遣使节试图与罗马人谈判，接下来发生了什么？好吧，他们到达了罗马营地，当他们靠近时，传来了一种震耳欲聋的号角声。然后他们进入营地，被带过整齐排列的军团，这些军团完全沉默。我的意思是，那一定很可怕。在他们前面是坐在讲台上的两位执政官，迦太基使节被带到了执政官面前。
and they start stammering, trying to make their excuses, but all these excuses are dismissed. And then one of the consuls, Lucius Marcius, censorinus, he informs the envoys that there will be no more negotiations until Carthage has handed over all the weapons in the city, all the armour, all the war machines. And so the envoys go back to Carthage and shortly afterwards great wagon loads of weapons and armor kind of rumbling up to the Roman camp. and also in their train over 2,000 catapults. So these are all handed over to the Romans.
他们开始结结巴巴，试图找借口，但所有这些借口都被驳回了。然后其中一位执政官，卢修斯·马尔修斯·岑索里努斯（Lucius Marcius Censorinus），通知使节，在迦太基交出城内所有的武器、所有的盔甲、所有的战争机器之前，不会再有任何谈判。于是使节们回到迦太基，不久之后，装满武器和盔甲的大马车隆隆地开向罗马营地。随行的还有2000多台投石机。所以这些都被交给了罗马人。
And then the envoys come back and they stand in front of the consuls again. And now at last the terms are delivered and I will quote them. Bear bravely the remaining commands of the Roman Senate, the envoys are told. You must evacuate your city and surrender it to us. You will be allowed to settle where you please within the limits of your own territory provided that it is at least 10 miles from the sea. As for us, we are resolved to level Carthage to the ground. I just mean, the Carthaginian envoy is listening to that.
然后使节们回来，再次站在执政官面前。现在终于提出了条款，我将引用它们。勇敢地承担罗马元老院剩余的命令，使节们被告知。你们必须撤离你们的城市并将其移交给我们。你们将被允许在你们自己领土范围内的任何地方定居，前提是距离大海至少10英里。至于我们，我们决心将迦太基夷为平地。我的意思是，迦太基使节听到这些话时。
I mean, terrifying. And of course, I mean, what can they do? There's no way that the Carthaginians can possibly accept this, you would think. I mean, just to emphasise for people, talked about how people are identified with their mother city. And in a sense, to lose your mother city is to lose your identity. that city, it's not just about the history, it's also about the temples, the gods, whatever. You know, you lose everything.
我的意思是，太可怕了。当然，我的意思是，他们能做什么？你可能会认为迦太基人绝不可能接受这一点。我的意思是，只是为了向人们强调，谈到人们如何认同他们的母城。从某种意义上说，失去你的母城就是失去你的身份。那座城市，不仅仅是关于历史，它还关于寺庙、神灵等等。你知道，你失去了一切。
And of course, I mean, on the economic sense, if you no longer have a port, you no longer really have a way of kind of making a living. So, as you say, I mean, it would seem impossible for the Carthaginians to accept these terms. And so it proves, because when the ambassadors from the Roman camp return to Carthage, the people of the city refuse to accept it, even though they know that in effect, by doing so they are signing their own death warrant. And anyone who speaks up saying, actually I think we should accept these terms,
当然，从经济意义上讲，如果你不再拥有港口，你就真的不再有谋生的方式了。所以，正如你所说，我的意思是，迦太基人似乎不可能接受这些条款。事实证明确实如此，因为当来自罗马营地的使节回到迦太基时，城里的人拒绝接受，尽管他们知道这样做实际上是在签署他们自己的死刑判决书。任何站出来说，其实我认为我们应该接受这些条款的人，
I mean, you know, we've got no chance of keeping the Romans at bay. They are lynched, they're stoned, whatever. And so there is a mass effort to try and steal Carthage for the horrors that are to come because, of course, they've handed over their catapults, their weapons, their armor, all of that. So what measures do they take? All the slaves in the city are freed, to the degree that the Carthage Union still have arms. arms are given to these slaves. People rush out to quarries outside the city and haul in stones because they're going to try and make more catapults. We're told all the shrines, the temples and
我的意思是，你知道，我们没有机会把罗马人拒之门外。他们被私刑处死，被乱石砸死，等等。所以人们进行了一场大规模的努力，试图为即将到来的恐怖做好准备，因为当然，他们已经交出了他们的投石机、武器、盔甲，所有这些。那么他们采取了什么措施？城里所有的奴隶都被释放了，只要迦太基人还有武器。武器被分发给这些奴隶。人们冲到城外的采石场，搬运石头，因为他们要尝试制造更多的投石机。我们被告知所有的神龛、寺庙和
every other public space was turned into workshops where men and women worked day and night without pause, taking turns to eat according to a fixed schedule. So basically, you know, equivalence of munitions factories popping up across the city in their temples. And in these workshops of course people are busy making swords spears shields anything made of metal in the city is being melted down and women donate their hair so that it can be used as rope for the catapults kind of twine it haztrable their general who'd lost the battle at orosoppa and is still on death row he's reprieved and he's given back his old command and he leads out a makeshift army and prepares for a guerrilla war against the romans and it is war for the
每一个其他的公共空间都被变成了车间，男人和女人日夜不停地工作，按照固定的时间表轮流吃饭。所以基本上，你知道，相当于在他们的寺庙里涌现出了军火工厂。在这些车间里，人们当然忙于制造剑、矛、盾牌，城里任何金属制品都被熔化了，妇女们捐出她们的头发，以便可以用作投石机的绳索，把它们搓在一起。哈斯德鲁巴，那位在奥罗斯科帕战败且仍在死囚名单上的将军，他被赦免了，并被恢复了旧职，他带领一支临时军队，准备对罗马人进行游击战，这是第三次战争，
third time, Rome and Carthage are locked in what really is this time a death struggle. It's not a death struggle for Rome, but it absolutely is for Carthage. So it's the kind of war, it's a bit like, I don't know, when the Nazis invaded Poland in 1939 and the Germans had such a preponderance of forces, but allied sympathizers with Poland sort of said, oh, you know, they will have all the pluck, you know, they've got such spirit, they're fighting for their home you know, the people will rise and they will see off the invaders, all of this kind of thing. And actually that turned out to be complete wishful thinking because the balance of forces was such that the attacker could not but win. And in this case, well, actually, it's not an immediate walkover, is it, by any means?
罗马和迦太基陷入了这次真的是生死搏斗的境地。这对罗马来说不是生死搏斗，但对迦太基来说绝对是。所以这是一种战争，有点像，我不知道，当纳粹在1939年入侵波兰时，德国人拥有如此压倒性的力量，但波兰的盟友同情者说，哦，你知道，他们会有所有的勇气，你知道，他们有这样的精神，他们为自己的家园而战，你知道，人民会站起来，他们会击退入侵者，所有这些事情。而实际上这被证明完全是一厢情愿，因为力量对比使得攻击者不可能不赢。而在这种情况下，嗯，实际上，这绝不是一场立即的轻松胜利，不是吗？
So the Carthaginians do actually manage to hold out for much longer than the Poles do against the Nazis, as it turns out for several years. And they're able to do this because even though the Carthaginians, have had to, you know, have been tricked into handing over so much of their weaponry. The city is still pretty well prepared for a siege. So it has the kind of great triple walls. And these walls in turn are buttressed with ditches and banks. And I mentioned the grain silos. So they have a lot of food inside the city. And they've also built huge cisterns for collecting rainwater. So again, water shouldn't be a problem. And meanwhile, the Romans, as they advance up to the city, they camp beside a stagnant lake and it's summer.
所以迦太基人确实设法比波兰人对抗纳粹坚持的时间长得多，事实证明坚持了几年。他们能够做到这一点，因为尽管迦太基人不得不，你知道，被诱骗交出了他们如此多的武器。这座城市仍然为围城做好了相当充分的准备。所以它有那种伟大的三重城墙。而这些城墙又用沟渠和堤岸加固。我提到了粮仓。所以他们在城内有很多食物。他们还建造了巨大的蓄水池来收集雨水。所以同样，水应该不是问题。与此同时，罗马人随着他们推进到城市，他们在死水湖旁扎营，而且是夏天。
And so predictably they all start, you know, catching various horrible diseases. And actually, Hasdrubal, who, you know, he proved an absolute dud in open combat. When it comes to guerrilla warfare, he's actually pretty good. He's very successful at attacking Roman supply lines, masterminding sallies. And so all that year, 149, the siege carries on, 148, Roman setbacks continue. they are going around trying to mop up Carthaginian strongholds beyond Carthage, but these two are able to hold out. And again, Sallies are launched out from the walls and they burn Roman siege engines and so on.
所以可以预见的是，他们都开始，你知道，感染各种可怕的疾病。实际上，哈斯德鲁巴，你知道，他在公开战斗中表现得非常糟糕。当谈到游击战时，他实际上相当不错。他在攻击罗马补给线、策划突袭方面非常成功。所以在那一年，149年，围城战继续，148年，罗马人的挫折继续。他们四处奔走，试图扫荡迦太基在迦太基之外的据点，但这些据点也能坚持住。同样，从城墙上发起了突袭，他们烧毁了罗马的攻城器械等等。
And then in 148, Massanissa, you know, the old warhorse, the man who had once been a Carthaginian ally and then become their great enemy, he dies at the fabulous age of 91. And that might have offered hope to the Carthaginians. perhaps, you know, that this kind of inveterate enemy of theirs has gone. And then there comes news from the Balkans that a pretender to the Macedonian throne has emerged. So people remember that the kingdom of Macedon had been divided up into these four cantons. A pretender has emerged and he wants to reunite these cantons and make himself king. And he defeats a Roman army and sends messages to the Carthaginian saying,
然后在148年，马西尼萨，你知道，那位老战马，曾经是迦太基盟友后来成为他们大敌的人，以91岁的高龄去世了。这可能给迦太基人提供了希望。也许，你知道，这个他们的宿敌已经走了。然后从巴尔干半岛传来消息，马其顿王位的觊觎者出现了。所以人们记得马其顿王国被分成了这四个州。一个觊觎者出现了，他想重新统一这些州并让自己成为国王。他击败了一支罗马军队，并向迦太基人发送信息说，
will you enter into an alliance? and of course the Carthaginians say yes. So suddenly they do have an ally. Now the Romans, you know, they're not despondent. They're still fully expecting to win. But I think there's a certain sense of alarm developing. And so they start to look around for a saviour. Someone qualified to step into the breach and prove himself a hero.
你们会结盟吗？当然迦太基人说是。所以突然间他们确实有了一个盟友。现在罗马人，你知道，他们并不沮丧。他们仍然完全期待获胜。但我认为出现了一种警觉感。所以他们开始寻找救星。一个有资格挺身而出并证明自己是英雄的人。
And there is, of course, really only the one candidate. So the obvious person, I guess, the adoptive grandson of Skippio Afrikanus, it's the person we've already talked about, Scipio Amelianus. And it's not just that he has got the right bloodline, or the right heredity. He has experienced, doesn't he? He has already fought the Carthaginians. He has. I mean, he's a very, very good soldier. So he'd been an observer at Oros Goppa where Massenissa had defeated the Carthaginians. And so he had seen Hasdrable, the Carthaginian commander in chief up close. You know, he knew what made him tick. And then for the past two years, he'd been serving before the walls of Carthage itself, where he was basically the only senior
当然，真的只有一个候选人。所以显而易见的人，我想，小西庇阿（Scipio Africanus）的养孙，就是我们已经谈过的人，小西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）。不仅仅是因为他有正确的血统，或者正确的遗传。他有经验，不是吗？他已经和迦太基人打过仗了。他确实打过。我的意思是，他是一个非常非常优秀的士兵。所以他曾是奥罗斯科帕的观察员，在那里马西尼萨击败了迦太基人。所以他近距离观察过迦太基总司令哈斯德鲁巴。你知道，他知道是什么让他动起来。在过去的两年里，他一直在迦太基城墙前服役，在那里他基本上是唯一一个获得任何荣誉的高级
officer to have emerged with any credit at all. I mean, he'd had a very good war. The only drawback is that he's still in his 30s, and people will remember that the minimum age to serve as consul is 40. That had been waived for Scipio Africanus against the opposition of Roman conservatives. But the people hadn't cared. They'd forced it through. And the same thing happens this time. The people, and I quote, declared that he was the only worthy successor of his father, Emilius Paulus, the conqueror of Macedon, and of the Scipio's. And so the Senate, recognizing the force of public opinion, perhaps, you know, just a little desperate themselves, agree to waive the prohibition and say, yeah, Skipio can run for consul and he's duly elected.
军官。我的意思是，他打了一场非常好的仗。唯一的缺点是他才30多岁，人们会记得担任执政官的最低年龄是40岁。这对小西庇阿来说已经被免除了，尽管遭到了罗马保守派的反对。但人民并不在乎。他们强行通过了。这次也发生了同样的事情。人民，我引用，宣称他是他的父亲，马其顿征服者埃米利乌斯·保卢斯（Emilius Paulus）和西庇阿家族唯一的合格继承人。所以元老院，也许认识到公众舆论的力量，也许他们自己也有一点绝望，同意免除禁令并说，是的，西庇阿可以竞选执政官，他被正式选上了。
And the intriguing thing is that even the absolute spokesman for conservatism, Cato, even Cato gives Scipio Emilianus the nod. I mean, he really is the right man for the job. So now at last we come to the final chapter in the story. So the siege of Carthage, the end of the Punic wars, and indeed the end of this great ancient city itself. So the Romans have put all their hopes in Scipio Amelianus. and when he arrives in Africa's consul in 146 Tom he has the the vigour and the dynamism and the ambition that his predecessors have lacked and he more than bears out the hope that the Senate had in him yes and hosrable who has clashed with scipio amelianus before i mean he's very respectful of his reputation and so he rather than continuing with his guerrilla war he withdraws all his troops inside carthage and hunkers down there
有趣的是，即使是保守主义的绝对代言人加图，甚至加图也对小西庇阿表示了认可。我的意思是，他确实是这份工作的合适人选。所以现在我们终于来到了故事的最后一章。所以迦太基围城战，布匿战争的结束，以及这座伟大的古城本身的终结。所以罗马人把所有的希望都寄托在小西庇阿身上。当他在公元前146年作为执政官到达非洲时，他拥有他的前任所缺乏的活力、动力和野心，他不仅仅实现了元老院对他的希望。是的，哈斯德鲁巴，他以前和小西庇阿发生过冲突，我的意思是，他非常尊重他的名声，所以他没有继续他的游击战，而是将他所有的军队撤回迦太基内部，并在那里固守。
But this, of course, is only to play into Skippy Emilianus's hands, because now all the Carthaginian forces are trapped inside the great city. And Emilianus knows that if he can only invest the city completely, completely surround it, cut off all supplies of food, then he will be able in the long run to starve the city into submission. And so he orders his men to start constructing a massive mole across the entrance of the harbour, which to the Carthaginian see. an impossible engineering project. But Skippy Emilianus is a very good engineer as well as a very good soldier and is able to pull it off. And so this mole ends up being constructed. Access to the harbour is now blocked off and there is no possibility of food coming into Carthage. And so Scipio Emilianus knows that he can now sit back and wait. And with each day that passes, the noose will tighten.
但这当然只是正中小西庇阿的下怀，因为现在所有的迦太基军队都被困在这座伟大的城市里。埃米利乌斯知道，如果他能完全封锁这座城市，完全包围它，切断所有的食物供应，那么从长远来看，他将能够通过饥饿迫使这座城市投降。于是他命令他的人在港口入口处建造一座巨大的防波堤，这对迦太基人来说是一个不可能的工程项目。但小西庇阿不仅是一位非常优秀的士兵，也是一位非常优秀的工程师，他能够做到这一点。所以这座防波堤最终被建造起来。进入港口的通道现在被封锁了，迦太基不可能再有食物进入。所以小西庇阿知道他现在可以坐下来等待。随着每一天的过去，绞索会越收越紧。
And what about the Carthaginians? Well, this noose is tightening. What are they doing? Well, Carthage has always been run by a Senate. In that sense, it's always had a kind of civilian government. But Hasdrubal, he feels that the only way that Carthage survive is if he institutes a military dictatorship. And so this is what he does. He's got all the soldiers that his back. There's no one to stop him. And by doing that, of course, he is able to commandeer all the food supplies within the city and ensure that his men are well-fetched. fed even while everyone else starts to starve and the corpses of those who no longer have access to food begin to litter the streets of the dying city. And Hasdrable is anxious that this experience of starvation on the part of the vast majority of the public may result in civic unrest, may lead to pressure on him to open negotiations with the Romans and he's not prepared to do that. So he takes Roman legionaries who've been captured in the fighting and he leads them up onto the walls of Carthage and there where the Romans far below can see what is being done to their comrades, they're tortured to death and their bodies are dumped into the Roman positions. So that of course makes sure that there will be no negotiations.
那迦太基人呢？好吧，这根绞索正在收紧。他们在做什么？好吧，迦太基一直由元老院管理。从这个意义上说，它一直有一种文官政府。但哈斯德鲁巴，他觉得迦太基生存的唯一途径是他建立军事独裁。所以这就是他所做的。他背后有所有的士兵。没有人能阻止他。通过这样做，当然，他能够征用城内所有的食物供应，并确保他的人吃得饱。即使当其他人开始挨饿，那些不再有食物来源的人的尸体开始散落在垂死的城市的街道上。哈斯德鲁巴很担心绝大多数公众的这种饥饿经历可能会导致公民动乱，可能会导致他面临与罗马人进行谈判的压力，而他并没有准备好那样做。所以他抓住了在战斗中被俘的罗马军团士兵，把他们带到迦太基的城墙上，在那里，远处的罗马人可以看到他们的战友正在遭受什么，他们被折磨致死，尸体被扔进罗马人的阵地。所以这当然确保了不会有任何谈判。
And Skippy Amelianis is waiting for the morale in the city to hit rock bottom for people really to start dying. for disease to spread. And then when that moment comes, he strikes. And he takes the Carthaginians completely by surprise. And his assault, it's not over the walls, it's through the harbors from the mole. That mole is a kind of launch pad. And so the Romans are able to, it's an amphibious attack. They go through the outer harbor into that inner harbor that the Carthaginians have just been built. And from there, there is easy access to the great marketplace in the center of the city. and once the Romans have breached the harbour defences, they pour into this marketplace and they essentially make it the base for the sack of the city that is now going to happen.
小西庇阿正在等待城里的士气降到最低点，等待人们真正开始死亡。等待疾病蔓延。然后当那一刻到来时，他发动了进攻。他让迦太基人完全措手不及。他的进攻，不是越过城墙，而是通过防波堤从港口进入。那座防波堤是一个发射台。所以罗马人能够，这是一次两栖攻击。他们穿过外港进入迦太基刚刚建造的内港。从那里，可以很容易地进入城市中心的巨大市场。一旦罗马人突破了港口防御，他们就涌入这个市场，他们基本上把它作为即将发生的洗劫城市的基地。
First of all, they strip this great temple that is standing there of all. It's gold, pile that gold up, and then they start literally disassembling the city brick by brick. So what they do, there are kind of very tight narrow streets fanning off from the marketplace, and there are blocks of housing that reach up six stories. And these are but the marketplace. And the houses that are adjacent to the marketplace, soldiers go in, they clear all the opposition from all the enemy
首先，他们剥夺了矗立在那里的这座伟大寺庙的所有金子，把金子堆起来，然后他们开始字面上地一块砖一块砖地拆除这座城市。所以他们所做的是，从市场延伸出非常狭窄的街道，有高达六层的住宅区。这些不仅仅是市场。士兵们进入与市场相邻的房屋，他们清除了所有敌人的抵抗，
from each of the stories of these houses. And then once the houses have been cleared, they take planks up to the top story and they lay them out across the kind of narrow streets below. And from there they can pass into the next... block of houses and they do the same. And the process just goes on and on and on. And once the houses have been cleared and the soldiers have gone from the one block to the next, they then set the houses on fire. And you get masonry, you get beams, you get the corpses of the slain,
从这些房屋的每一层。然后一旦房屋被清理干净，他们就把木板带到顶层，铺在下面狭窄的街道上。从那里他们可以进入下一个……房屋街区，他们也做了同样的事情。这个过程就这样一直持续下去。一旦房屋被清理干净，士兵们从一个街区转移到下一个街区，他们就放火烧毁这些房屋。你会得到砖石，你会得到横梁，你会得到被杀者的尸体，
you get old men, women, children who might have taken shelter inside these houses. They all come crashing down into the streets. And we have a horrific discreet. of what this was like. Once all the kind of the debris has fallen into the streets, cleaners came, who had been charged with making the streets passable, so that the soldiers can continue up the streets. And these cleaners hauled the dead and the living alike into great pits they had dug, disposing of them as though they were masonry and burning timbers, mere debris.
你会得到可能在这些房屋内避难的老人、妇女、儿童。他们全都倒塌在街道上。我们有一个关于这看起来是什么样子的可怕描述。一旦所有碎片都掉进街道，清洁工就来了，他们负责让街道变得可以通过，以便士兵们可以继续沿街前进。这些清洁工把死者和活人一起拖进他们挖的大坑里，像处理砖石和燃烧的木材、仅仅是碎片一样处理他们。
Some of the living were thrown in headfirst, so that their legs stuck out of the ground, and they were left to writhe where they had been buried a long time. So a kind of hideous, grotesque, image. Do you know what it reminds me of? It reminds me of the siege of Tenostitlan that we talked about in the four of the Aztecs, the Spanish fighting house by house, destroying the houses to stop the Aztecs from using them as kind of refuges. I mean, it's very, very similar, isn't it? It's this Starlingrad-style battle. I mean, it's possible that there would have been Spaniards. Of course.
一些活人被头朝下扔进去，以至于他们的腿从地里伸出来，他们被留在那里挣扎，就在他们被埋葬的地方。所以这是一种可怕的、怪诞的形象。你知道它让我想起了什么吗？它让我想起了我们谈到的阿兹特克人灭亡中的特诺奇蒂特兰围城战，西班牙人逐屋战斗，摧毁房屋以阻止阿兹特克人将它们用作避难所。我的意思是，这非常非常相似，不是吗？这是一场斯大林格勒式的战斗。我的意思是，可能有西班牙人。当然。
In the war, who had read these very accounts. I was thinking that. Yeah, they had classical education a lot of these people, so they would have known about all this. And this, the destruction of Carthage is the archetype of the destruction of a great and famous and beautiful capital. And the process of clearance goes on for six days. And on the seventh day, the vast mass of the Carthaginians who remained alive, surrendered. And the only resistance now is from Hasdrubal and 900 Roman deserters who held out on the kind of the topmost fort, the Carthaginian equivalent of an Acropolis. But in time, he too is brought to surrender and he's brought before Scipio Amelianus and grovels before the feet of the Roman commander.
在战争中，读过这些记载的人。我当时就在想那个。是的，这些人中有很多受过古典教育，所以他们会知道这一切。而这，迦太基的毁灭，是伟大、著名和美丽的首都毁灭的原型。清理过程持续了六天。第七天，剩下的大部分迦太基人投降了。现在唯一的抵抗来自哈斯德鲁巴和900名罗马逃兵，他们坚守在最顶端的堡垒上，相当于迦太基的卫城。但最终，他也被迫投降，被带到小西庇阿面前，在罗马指挥官脚下卑躬屈膝。
And his wife, who'd been with him, is utterly contemptuous of this. And she takes a dagger, she slits the throats of their two sons, and she throws the corpses of her sons into a fire that is blazing nearby. And then she hurls herself into the flames as well. Very diedo. Yeah. I mean, it's a bit sad that women tend only to appear in the series when they're killing themselves. That's antiquity for you.
他的妻子，一直和他在一起，对此极其蔑视。她拿出一把匕首，割断了他们两个儿子的喉咙，并将她儿子的尸体扔进附近燃烧的火中。然后她也投身于火焰中。非常狄多（Dido）。是的。我的意思是，有点悲哀的是，女性往往只有在自杀时才会出现在这个系列中。这就是古代。
Yeah. So what happens to Hasdrubal and what happens to the deserters? The Hasdribal is spared and taken back to Rome, where he walks in Skippy Amelianus's triumph, and then he's allowed to settle in a farm outside Rome, so he survives. The Roman deserts, of course, are put horribly to death. The Carthaginians who've surrendered, they are all enslaved, about 50,000 of them. They're led out. Men, women, children, all become slaves.
是的。那么哈斯德鲁巴和逃兵们发生了什么？哈斯德鲁巴被饶恕并被带回罗马，他在小西庇阿的凯旋式中游行，然后他被允许在罗马郊外的一个农场定居，所以他活了下来。罗马逃兵当然被极其可怕地处死了。投降的迦太基人，他们都被奴役了，大约有5万人。他们被带出来。男人、女人、孩子，都成了奴隶。
The city is systematically stripped of all its treasures. No respect is shown the temples of the Carthaginian gods. They are demolished. Carthage had a rich and venerable literary tradition. All the libraries are emptied and given to the Numidians who promptly seem to have lost them. The Romans do keep one 28-volume treatise on agriculture, which they have translated into Latin, because obviously, they're thinking, well, we want to take over these lands.
这座城市被系统地剥夺了所有的宝藏。对迦太基神灵的寺庙没有表现出任何尊重。它们被拆毁了。迦太基拥有丰富而古老的文学传统。所有的图书馆都被清空并交给了努米底亚人，他们似乎很快就丢失了它们。罗马人确实保留了一部28卷的农业论著，他们将其翻译成拉丁文，因为显然，他们在想，好吧，我们想接管这些土地。
And this is the guide to how to, you know, how to make the fields flourish. So we'll keep that. But otherwise, all the wealth of Punic literature is gone. So we have nothing. We have no histories written by the Carthaginians. And so as so often, you know, in these stories, whether it's the Belgians in the Congo or whatever. Yeah. Or indeed the, you know, the Americans in the Great Plains.
这是关于如何，你知道，如何让田野繁荣的指南。所以我们会保留那个。但除此之外，布匿文学的所有财富都消失了。所以我们一无所有。我们没有迦太基人写的历史。所以正如经常发生的那样，你知道，在这些故事中，无论是刚果的比利时人还是其他什么。是的。或者确实是，你知道，大平原上的美国人。
We only have one side. We only have the Roman side. Yeah. The news of Carthage's fall is sent to Rome and the Senate then sent back instructions to Skippy Emilianus that what remained of the city was to be raised to the ground and that a curse was to be laid on anyone who in the future might try to settle there.
我们只有一方。我们只有罗马的一方。是的。迦太基陷落的消息被传到罗马，元老院随后向小西庇阿发回指示，要求将城市剩余的部分夷为平地，并对未来任何试图在那里定居的人施加诅咒。
So Carthage is to be left abandoned to weeds. But here's an amazing thing. They don't sew the ruins with salt. They don't. Everyone thinks they did that and they didn't. No, they don't. It was a metaphorical flourish in the Cambridge ancient history. which came out in the 1920s.
所以迦太基将被遗弃给杂草。但这里有一件令人惊奇的事情。他们没有在废墟上撒盐。他们没有。每个人都认为他们那样做了，但他们没有。不，他们没有。那是《剑桥古代史》中的一个隐喻性的修辞，出版于1920年代。
And it's just spread like wildfire ever since. But that did, you know, there's no reference to that happening in any of the ancient sources at all. But, you know, they might as well have sowed the fields with salt because the signal that the destruction of this very famous, very ancient, very beautiful city, the signal sent to the world was unmistakable that the Romans are no longer prepared to brook any rival, any hint of disobedience. And that is a message that is rammed home a few months later. So people may remember that, you know, there's this uprising in Macedon, this pretender to the Macedonian throne
从那以后它就像野火一样蔓延开来。但是，你知道，在任何古代文献中都没有提到过这种情况。但是，你知道，他们还不如在田野里撒盐，因为这座非常著名、非常古老、非常美丽的城市的毁灭所发出的信号，向世界发出的信号是明确的，即罗马人不再准备容忍任何竞争对手，任何不服从的暗示。而这个信息在几个月后被强化了。所以人们可能记得，你知道，马其顿发生了起义，这个马其顿王位的觊觎者
has emerged. I mean, he does not last long. He gets crushed. And there's then a kind of, there's an uprising in Greece and the Romans deal with that very brutally as well. And the suppression of that uprising culminates in the annihilation of a second famous, ancient and beautiful city. And that is the destruction of Corinth in Greece, commanding the isthmus that joins the Peloponnese to northern Greece. And I think that anyone in the Mediterranean in 146 BC contemplating the destruction in the same year of Carthage and of Corinth are well aware that an era has dawned in which Rome is so preponderant that effectively no one in the Mediterranean has any real independence left at all. And within a century, the whole of the Mediterranean will become a Roman lake. But the story of how Rome rises to that position of preponderance, what it means for people in the Mediterranean and what it means for the Romans themselves, I mean, that is a story for another
出现了。我的意思是，他没有持续多久。他被粉碎了。然后发生了一种，希腊发生了起义，罗马人也极其残酷地处理了那件事。那次起义的镇压以第二座著名、古老而美丽的城市的毁灭而告终。那就是希腊科林斯的毁灭，控制着连接伯罗奔尼撒半岛和希腊北部的地峡。我认为公元前146年地中海的任何人，在同一年目睹了迦太基和科林斯的毁灭，都非常清楚一个时代已经到来，在这个时代中，罗马是如此占据优势，以至于实际上地中海没有人再拥有任何真正的独立了。在一个世纪内，整个地中海将成为罗马的内湖。但关于罗马如何上升到那种优势地位的故事，这对地中海的人民意味着什么，对罗马人自己意味着什么，我的意思是，那是另一个故事
day. But I just thought to end this series, we've done three series in all. And we began the very first series with a passage that derives from Polybius' recollections. Polybius had accompanied Skippio Amelianus to the siege and had witnessed it for himself, so I'll just finish by reading this passage. It is said that Skippio Amelianus, as Carthage was going up in flames, its annihilation almost complete, gazed at the city in its death rose, and openly wept for his enemies. He stood wrapped in thought for a long time, pondering how every city, every people, every empire must, as men do, meet with their doom in the end. For such had been the fate of Troy,
的一天。但我只是想结束这个系列，我们总共做了三个系列。我们在第一个系列开始时引用了一段源自波利比乌斯（Polybius）回忆的段落。波利比乌斯曾陪同小西庇阿参加围城战并亲眼目睹了它，所以我将通过阅读这段文字来结束。据说小西庇阿，当迦太基在火焰中升起，其毁灭几乎完成时，凝视着这座处于垂死挣扎中的城市，并为他的敌人公开流泪。他长时间陷入沉思，思考着每一座城市、每一个民族、每一个帝国，正如人类一样，最终必须面对他们的厄运。因为这就是特洛伊的命运，
once a proud and flourishing city, and of the empires of Assyria, media and Persia, each in their own day the greatest in the world, and of Macedon, which only recently had blazed with such a brilliance. And then, either deliberately, or because he could not help quoting them, Scipio spoke two lines of Homer. day will come when sacred Troy shall perish, and Priam and his people all be slain. And when Polybius, speaking to him with the freedom he was granted, as Scipio's tutor in Greek literature, asked him what he meant by these words. It is said that without any attempt to veil his meaning, Scipio made reference to his own country. For when he pondered how all things that are mortal must fall. He dreaded how Rome two would fall.
曾经是一座骄傲而繁荣的城市，以及亚述、米底和波斯帝国，每一个在他们自己的时代都是世界上最伟大的，还有马其顿，它不久前还闪耀着如此的光辉。然后，要么是故意的，要么是因为他忍不住引用它们，西庇阿说了两句荷马的诗。神圣的特洛伊终将毁灭的日子会到来，普里阿摩斯和他的子民都将被杀。当波利比乌斯以他作为西庇阿希腊文学导师所被赋予的自由与他交谈，问他这些话是什么意思时。据说西庇阿没有试图掩饰他的意思，提到了他自己的国家。因为当他思考所有必死的事物都必须倒下时。他担心罗马也会倒下。
Craigie. Well, thank you very much, Tom. That's a salutary warning. And indeed, one that sets up beautifully our next series on The Rest is History, which will be starting on Monday. And that series is the tale of the fall of the Incas, one of the longest and largest contiguous empires in world history that came crashing down at the hands of Francisco Pizarro and his conquistadors. So on Monday, members of the rest is history club will get all six episodes in that mighty series. And if you want to join them, if you want to plunge into the streets of Cusco and Cajamaka and the jungles of the Amazon and scale the peaks of the Andes with the Spaniards,
克雷吉（Craigie）。好吧，非常感谢你，汤姆。这是一个有益的警告。事实上，这为我们在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）中的下一个系列做了很好的铺垫，该系列将于周一开播。那个系列是关于印加帝国灭亡的故事，这是世界历史上最长、最大的连续帝国之一，在弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗（Francisco Pizarro）和他的征服者手中崩溃。所以周一，历史俱乐部其余部分的成员将获得那个强大系列的所有六集。如果你想加入他们，如果你想潜入库斯科和卡哈马卡的街道，潜入亚马逊丛林，并与西班牙人一起攀登安第斯山脉的山峰，
then you merely have to head to the rest is history.com to sign up and you'll get all six episodes on Monday. But for now, Tom, what an amazing effort
那么你只需要前往therestisistory.com注册，你将在周一获得所有六集。但现在，汤姆，多么了不起的努力
to cover that epic story in three mighty seasons. Thank you so much. And that was Carthage. Bye, everybody. Ave, Aquivali. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在三个强大的季节里涵盖了那个史诗般的故事。非常感谢你。那就是迦太基。再见，大家。Ave，Aquivali。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。